I do have to get right into it because
Alex did just welcome his baby how do
you guys feel have you talked to him did
you send gifts oh no I'm really happy
for him I mean I hope that this will be
one of the changing factors in his lives
I think that he needed to shift where he
was focusing on in life and I think this
would be really good I hope that he it
makes him change his daughter and I
think this could be one of the best
things that will ever happen to him and
so I'm really hoping that maybe he's no
longer gonna be the person that he used
to be okay what about you Madison
um yeah I have talked to him and Alyssa
since their baby was born and they were
both extremely happy and they said it
was the best experience of their life oh
I'm really really happy for them
juliette last time I talked to you I
mean I feel like things were still
pretty sour looking ahead at what we're
gonna see this season I think we're
gonna get answers I think you're
probably gonna let Alyssa know maybe
what happened between you and Alex how
how are you feeling about watching all
of that back and what is your guys is
friendship relationship well I don't
like the way that I handled the
situation
it wasn't very fair it wasn't nice I
hold a total mean girl moves and I wish
I could change the way that all happened
but in my own defense I think that I was
pushed to the edge I had given him ample
opportunity to do the right thing and he
kept manipulating and lying and trying
to pretend that he had never done
anything wrong and I just kind of got to
the point where I was not okay with it
and I think I kind of projected my anger
towards him on her and that wasn't fair
but you know everything kind of happened
really fast and you're gonna see that
everything starts to change when you
find out she was having a baby so my
actions are not good though Madison you
and Alex
so have some history do you guys think
this is going to change him what I know
he's like not very pleased about how
he's portrayed in the first few episodes
coming back I personally think that he
will be a great father I always have
thought that though he loves kids
I just wonder that he may not be fully
like available as a father should be
because that's a full-time job everyone
improperly and I would be interested to
see if he really guys commit I don't
know if he's gonna completely commit to
her I don't think that he will but I
think the most important thing is
whether or not he's gonna be a good
father and I really really hope that he
will be I think he loves his daughter
with everything he has but it's more
I've been just loved you have to be
there as a parent so thank you
interested to see that you don't think
they're gonna last you Melissa
I mean no I don't I he I know that he
never wanted to date in the first place
he didn't want to be in a relationship I
mean him and I just got out of a
relationship you it's not healthy to
just jump back into something let alone
have a baby with a person you've been
dating for a couple months right we're
not there in love now and all that I
don't know but I don't think he's ready
to settle down okay Madison do you agree
I mean it's definitely gonna be the
biggest test to any relationship ever
right like having a child so I mean if
they work great if they don't I think
that's okay too
I think co-parenting is very doable
these days and I think both of them are
gonna be amazing parents have you talked
to him are you excited for him
how was he doing I have not talked to
him about that um I am so excited for
this baby to be here I think Alessi is
her name is going to help him grow at
least I hope so I think alex has a lot
on his plate a lot of growing to do I
know that the families are both on the
show a lot
her family this season and I I mean Alex
and I have seen each other less than
five times
the last nine months Wow why what
happened there you'll see Juliet seems
to think that him and ELISA will not
work out long term even though there's a
baby involved you guys both know Alex
very well do you agree with that
statement it just depends whether she
wants to put up with him cheating or not
so that's she may be the type of girl
that is okay with that I don't really
know her that well is he he's still
cheating on her
I would alex is gonna cheat on whoever
he's with for a very long time okay
Garrett I know you and Alex haven't
always been the friendliest people how
do you feel do you think him having a
baby will change him and we'll
relationship yeah I mean I think that I
mean I don't really ever talk to him
other than he's kind of contacting me
about you know work out stuff and
whatnot I don't know them both that well
to know exactly what's gonna happen but
I always have the best for people and
especially having a baby in the world is
a big thing so is there growth for Alex
this season because from what I know
he's actually pretty upset at how things
play out in the first few episodes yeah
I there is zero growth zero growth do
you ever see yourself reconciling with
him or being friends with him again are
you do you feel like you've just been
put through the wringer one too many
times I like my dad because I feel like
your dad he would just have like I'm
just growing so much and we are on very
different wavelengths of life and I hope
of course that he froze do you guys know
if there were cameras rolling in the in
the delivery room this weekend do you
know we're gonna see that in a season
four potentially I think that they are
very open to showing a lot and I think
that they did this season and from my
understanding of what I've heard you see
Alyssa's family really put Alex through
the wringer and I think that's gonna
show through and I don't see why they
wouldn't show everything because
it's what they do this season so I don't
know why they would all of a sudden not
right
did you do something right you chose a
bag over me
do you regret taking the purse from him
no no thank you
I regret why but I so deserve that purse
from Alex they don't want to say what
I'm going to do but like I definitely
feel in my heart that like ELISA
deserves more in our apology and I don't
know
you'll see
[Music]